My mother was a uh... Italian immigrant
at the time she was married had to come here
two years before my dad even though they were
married
and she was working on a factory in Cambridge
and uh...
and then uh...  Kennedy I think was running
for Congress at the time and
uh... was given a speech to the factory workers
and she was wispearing something for her friend
and
JFK asked a friend
what did your friend say
and my mom, my mom's friend reply cause
my mom couldn't speak any english she wanna know
why she's married
was able to come to this country when her husband couldent
come over
and JFK reply something along the lines
that it was a
it was something he was aware
and uh... and it was
something he was focused on two bring
to bring family togethers and allow immigrants the same opportunity
in this country that immigrants for generations
had had at that time
and uh... something a story that i
didn't know till a few years back
that my mother stills retells today
my dad would tell me that as new people to this
country
that he felt that they were inspired by his
caring and compassion for all mankind and
all people all citizens than people want to
play positive role in in in this country and
they felt like he protected them
and and for many italian immigrants uh... and
I some Italian immigrants that was very inspirational
I often tell people you know I like being the mayor but
I love doing the job I love doing the job
because i feel like to make a difference as
mayor
to make my community better place to live
work play and raise a family in and those
are JFK's words ringing true in my mind
that's the service
not the position that's greatness
and you could take it in to different perspective
I can achieve greatness by being elected
or I can achieve greatness
by doing the service and its the service
that moves me every day